look to us you know
he's a resilient kid i don't know if
there's a message or
anything to take from it is you know the
same message the entire team
gets we all have to do we all have to
play better we've got to coach better
he's not in this alone he's got my full
support he's got the support of the car
coaching staff he's got support of
everyone
every every player on in that locker
room
and conversely he supports all the other
players
in the locker room as well so i don't
know if there's a message here
or you don't make too much of this he's
the starting quarterback
he knows that we've had that
conversation
he's played well you know
and and you know he's gonna i expect him
to continue to play well i expect him to
bounce back
brian flores dolphins coach from monday
explaining the benching of tuatanga
vailoa whether it was because of poor
performance whether it was for his own
protection because he was getting
hammered by the
front seven of the denver broncos you
know chris i just keep coming back to
something cam newton said several weeks
ago when he was concerned about the
mistakes he was making he said players
talk
that's my concern how do you lead the
locker room how do you lead the team
if you are a guy who is susceptible to
being yanked off the field at any time
we don't see this happen
often in the nfl the last time it
happened was
13 years ago when dennis green then the
head coach of the
arizona cardinals would take out
matt liner and put in kurt warner
and then when kurt warner would
stabilize things he'd put matt leinart
back in
right uh usually you've got one
quarterback he's your guy
until he's injured or benched not just
temporarily but benched for good
what do you think about this after
having one day for the dust to settle
and hearing what coach flores had to say
yeah i mean i i'm not like panicked
about it i mean i i
believe everything kind of blind brian
flores says about the subject you know i
know what you're saying too
it might be different with players
talking if it was an established
starting veteran quarterback
who had issues and things like that but
those guys in the locker room know
this is still early he's a young player
he's just got out there so they're not
gonna like
you know judge anything too harshly or
be like oh he can't lead us he's not not
not yet not there yet
but i will say this too you know the
more i more and i'm gonna watch this
film when we get done with the show
today is the next one i want to watch
because i want to see what went on
but just from watching on tv and what we
saw
and what we see with this stat line and
everything there
you know to me it shows more than you
know
oh he was just getting beat up and they
need a jumpstart they didn't like
something they were seeing about the
football game and that tua was playing
11 for 20 with one interception i mean
one touchdown
and no interception doesn't necessarily
lend itself
to oh my gosh it's so bad we got to get
him out of there and get him out of the
game
now he took a lot of sacks was he under
a little pressure yes
but to me more than anything watching on
tv too was
you know it seems like we saw a young
quarterback who was very confused about
what he was
seeing all day long holding the ball not
getting the ball out of his hands
unwilling to pull the trigger at times
and make throw into tight windows
and again i can't see it all but between
the way the game was going
you know his stat line and everything
there i think it was purely done to
hey our young guy doesn't got it today
he's a little overwhelmed let's get fitz
in here
and see if he can make some magic happen
and jump start us and maybe we can get
out of here with a win
i think the key stat on that graphic was
six sacks i really do think there was an
element of we have to protect this guy
we can't afford to have him injured and
miss multiple weeks if this is just a
game where he is going to be overwhelmed
and the offensive line isn't going to
keep the denver defense away from him
sufficiently we we have to pull the rip
cord
and and throw the backup out there
because if anybody's going to get hurt
today it's going to be the backup
yeah listen you know young quarterback
seeing crazy coverages doing things like
that
hey you can get overwhelmed and then you
can start to lose like
we showed a play on football night in
america there was a blitz he's got a hot
route throw it to him he kind of looks
at him and then doesn't know where to go
after that you know so i think there's
still growing pains going on here
let alone yeah he was you know getting
beat up a little bit
definitely and i think they just went
you're right let's get somebody in here
see what we can do but this is to me
you know where we're gonna we're gonna
see more about tua
this is where i i'm interested in him
and where
you know again the bootlegs the screens
the defense the special teams they
weren't there
you know will tua be able to make throws
in the pocket into tight
windows and and do that type of stuff to
me that was the big question there
and this was the first game he was kind
of put in that position and it didn't go
great and i don't want to hur
judge harshly but it's just something to
look out for
as we go forward here and when you study
that film remember what he said to me
last week after the chargers game
it's not as hard as i thought it was
going to be not that it's not hard and
he
said he thought he would see a lot more
different looks well now he did
and that's part of the challenge they're
putting a ceiling above you
can you bust through it before they bust
you up as they were doing
on sunday hi i'm mike tarico and thanks
for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports